we're here
to wreck something.
- Yes, yes, absolutely.
- Party, wreck something.
- I am extremely excited
to smash and cut
and just completely
obliterate whatever I can.
I'm here to have fun.
How about you?
- I'm a fat old man;
I'm supposed to be dead
32 years ago.
Here I am to party.
- If I remember correctly,
you told me
you were an extreme
sport athlete.
- Yeah, I was on
"Forged in Fire."
How about you?
- Yeah, I did a little
preparation.
I drank a lot of beer
at The Forge,
got a lot of good
hammer strikes in.
Yeah.
- [grunts]
- You do any martial arts
in your past?
- Uh, well, I used to do
SCA fencing.
- Used to?
- Used to.
- Gave that up?
- Yeah, I got fat.
You got--fencing is for fat,
old guys
that are mostly dead.
- Yeah.
- It's nice.
Never--no heavy stick
fighting?
- Nah, well, I did that
when I was 15.
Then I got in a motorcycle
accident, wrecked my knees.
- You were mostly dead.
- I was mostly dead.
In many different ways.
As I said, I look pretty darn
good for a corpse.
- You look good for a corpse,
yeah.
- Perambulatin' corpse.
- Pre-ambulating.
- Per-rambulatin'.
- Perambulate, that means
you can walk or--
- That's a fancy word.
- Yeah, that's a fancy word.
- I went to college and all.
So what do you normally make?
- Uh, whatever historically
catches my interest.
I wanted to learn how to do
socketed spears.
I probably made--
less than 100,
but I've made a lot of spears,
all one piece.
Figure it out, that's what
I like to do.
- Yeah, I've been doing
mostly historical stuff.
I did a couple of Viking
wolf's tooth.
I did a seax
in a wolf's tooth.
I did a dagger in
a wolf's tooth pattern.
- Right on.
- Based, actually--
I got a friend who's got
a couple of artifact
Viking wolf tooth spears.
- Cool.
- So I kinda based that on
the actual artifacts
I've handled.
So what do you do
for a day gig?
- For a day job
instead of blacksmithing
in the dead of night?
I'm a correction officer.
Been doing that for about
17 years.
- So you seen all sorts
of shanks and stuff.
- I've seen a lot of homemade
weapons, yes.
Yep, pretty interesting things
that would not
do well on these
kind of courses,
but for up close,
personal combat,
yeah, yeah.
I train for that, you know.
If somebody's gonna attack you
in hand-to-hand kind of
takedown stuff--
trapping weapons, you know,
gaining the upper hand.
It might come in handy.
I don't know.
I'm in okay shape.
I'm not mostly dead.
One foot in the grave, maybe,
but I'm not mostly dead.
- I'm a jeweler. [laughs]
I make little shiny things.
- Jewelry's good. Yeah, yeah.
Did you make that on
your shirt there?
- Oh, yeah.
- Nice. Yeah, saw that earlier.
- Yeah, I work in gold,
silver, bronze,
high carbon steel.
- High carbon steel.
Have you done any cutting
competitions ever?
- Nope.
- Neither have I. Not a one.
- Nah, I didn't even really
get a chance
to touch my blade.
I'm not--here's hoping.